that same morning president bush was in
florida visiting emma booker elementary
school everyone remembers the scene
where students were reading a book
it was called the pet goat now he
already knew the first plane that hit
the world trade center at the time
people thought it was an accident
somehow but minutes later the second
plane hit the white house chief of staff
andy card needed to tell the president
page 153.
a second plane hit the second tower
america is under attack or his words ari
fleischer was the former white house
press secretary spent the entire day
with president bush
ari take us through those
first moments
you were there for every minute of it
you know as the motorcade pulled up to
the emma booker elementary school i got
a page and it said
playing us at the world trade center i
thought accident small plane and then
about 30 seconds before andy card walked
into that room and whispered in the
president's right ear
i was leaning against the left wall of
that room about 20 feet over from the
president's left shoulder
and i got a second page and the second
page told me
second plane is at the second tower
and i just knew at that moment laura
that it was terrorism
and let's just start to brace and get
ready for everything that i knew would
have to unfold as the united states
defended itself
the president had to be whisked away for
national security reasons
to the extent you can tell us what
happened
please do tell us what happened shortly
thereafter
well interestingly the secret service
did not think we were under an immediate
threat otherwise they never would have
let him go to the gym at that school
where he addressed the nation spoke very
briefly talked about the terrorist
attack in our country then we quickly
got into the motorcade and started
flying to air force one that's when the
third plane hit the pentagon we learned
about it in the motorcade we boarded air
force one and laura when we boarded the
president was told there are still six
aircraft in the sky that have not
responded to the order to land so at
that moment we knew aboard air force one
three planes that hit their targets
there are six more missiles in the sky
a little while after that we got another
word another bit of information saying a
plane went down near camp david now camp
david is about 100 miles from
shanksville but the first report on air
force one was near camp david
at the same time the media was full of
stories about there's a car bomb at the
state department the mall is on fire at
10 32 that morning we got a the
president was on the phone with the
bunker and the vice president the bunker
said to him we got a call at the white
house saying angel is next
angel is the secret service code word
for air force one
that sent a shiver down the pilot's
spine of air force one making him think
is this an inside job
who could possibly have the code word
for air force one he actually stationed
the air force security officer at the
steps going up to the cockpit on air
force one to make certain that nobody
could come up those steps and take down
air force one
it was just a swirl of information much
of it wrong
all of it's scary now ari i want to play
this cockpit report recording from
united flight 93
which was the one that was believed to
be headed toward either the white house
or the capitol building
united 93 that traffic for you is one
o'clock 12 miles eastbound 370. negative
contact we're looking united 93.
united 93 cleveland if you hear the
center right then i got that
[Music]
where were you in the president at that
point
that is we were aboard air force one we
did not hear those audio tapes until
days later after september 11th we
didn't hear those on air force one uh
and of course that's the plane that went
down in shanksville
and and
you know
that's the heroism of the crew of the
passengers that took down that plane the
911 commission
having studied it they reported that
there was is never going to be known
whether the target of that plane was
going to be either the white house or
the capital the hijackers were actually
arguing about which of those two targets
they were going to go after and we will
never have that resolved and ari the the
question that it was always discussed in
the years afterward what who gave the
order to be able to take down
united 93 or any civilian aircraft if it
was understood to be an immediate threat
to
the president or washington or any other
installation how did that unfold
anywhere
that originally was a decision made or
action taken in the bunker underneath
the white house by dick cheney
that was brought to the president the
president approved it there is some
issue about the sequencing of that
decision
i think that the decision was first made
in the bunker then it got passed up to
the president the president authorized
it
you know the communications on air force
one that day this is another one of the
little known stories was terrible
the phone from the president down to the
bunker cut out on several occasions
which is absolutely amazing the air
force one of all places which should be
designed so at a moment of heightened
crisis
everything works perfectly the
communications kept cutting out ari just
one final question when you see the
taliban in control the u.s having to
rely on them for security and getting
planes out
on the 20th anniversary of 9 11.
i got to get your take on that
you know laura when i saw the pictures
of the new government the taliban
government in those little snapshot
pictures my first thought was those are
the very same pictures that i watched
the president put an x through
as we arrested them or we brought them
to justice and killed them
and now joe biden's restored them to
power that was my first thought we took
those people out joe biden brought them
right back
it's just uh ari i i'm so happy you came
on
we can never forget what happened that
day and thank you so much for your
perspective and your your memories
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else